[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday
September 6th I'd like to congratulate
you on another great song although as
one commenter pointed out I'm kind of
scared of the dark side of Hank green
I mean seriously Hank the last time I
saw you that angry I was warning that
being the older brother isn't
necessarily the same thing as being the
stronger brother some people were
terrified of your homicidal mania but
not me Hank
I know better you're just trying to
toughen up your image it's like when
Britney Spears released toxic I do
however have one small criticism of your
song Hank
scorpions fatality was clearly taking
off his mask and then breathing fire so
that you become just bones sub-zero's
fatality was the ripping off of the
spine duh Hank the vitriolic hatred for
Hummers you expressed in your last video
reminded me of something the Brotherhood
2.0 book club that's right Hank like
jeans with high waists the Indonesian
economy and the acting career of John
Travolta the Brotherhood 2.0 book club
is back I've just finished reading deep
economy by Bill McKibben the book that
you assigned me back in like February
Hank I really did like the book it
argues that more is no longer equivalent
to good and that economic growth as
we've always constructed it has stopped
giving us what we're looking for I have
to say Hank that it is hard for me to
imagine a world that doesn't rely upon
economic growth to determine success but
McKibben makes a pretty compelling
argument that by doing this were really
screwing ourselves for the future there
was one thing right at the beginning of
the book that really got to me that I
want to talk about McKibben pointed out
that if people in China owned cars at
the same percentage that people in
America owned cars then the total number
of cars in the world would immediately
double I went ahead and I did some math
actually I didn't do the math I called
Daniel and I found out that if everyone
in the world owned cars the same rate
that Americans do then the number of
cars in the world would be like five
times greater than what it is now and
our atmosphere couldn't handle that much
carbon dioxide in very short order human
life would become impossible and that's
what troubles me Hank that's what
troubles me about my whole life in
Indiana as compared to my life in New
York when I lived in New York I had an
apartment I think everybody should have
a safe place to live I had access to
excellent public transportation which I
think everyone should have I had places
where I could afford to buy food which I
think everyone should have and I had a
good independent bookstore which I think
everyone should have so when I lived in
New York all of the things that I had
were things that I think everyone should
have now that I live in Indianapolis I
own a car but I don't want everyone to
own a car because then you know I would
die I would suck so if the world would
be destroyed by everyone owning a car
how come I feel entitled to own a car
that bugs me Hank what I kept thinking
when I was reading deep economy is that
I want to be living a life that everyone
could live without the world ending I
mean there's something pretty sick about
living a life that's dependent upon an
underclass anyway Hank thanks for the
recommendation I definitely enjoyed deep
economy even though it didn't contain
any like love stories or car chases or
metaphors about existential isolation
like most of the books I like I'm also
excited to announce the next book in the
Brotherhood 2.0 book club which is going
to be Paper Towns by me Hank penguin
won't be publishing Paper Towns until
September of next year but I'm going to
make a draft of the book available to
you and to Kathryn in a couple of weeks
how I'm going to do that without
actually communicating with you remains
to be seen but I'm sure I can figure
something out I'll see you tomorrow